on va parler d'abord d'une d'une autre
star euh juste avant d'ailleurs de
parler d'un autre star de parler de Gard
pard jure sur l'affaire Pierre Palmade
un an après le terrible accident causé
par Pierre Palm qui a touché de plein
fou et une voiture transportant trois
personnes la femme blessée dans le choc
a perdu son bébé et apparemment elle
serait pas bien du tout qu'est-ce qui se
passe non elle va pas bien du tout alors
déjà pas bien physiquement parce que
elle a eu elle a eu des vertèbres
fracturé la dentition également elle a
eu un décollement de l'omoplate elle a
du mal à tendre ses ses bras elle
souffre encore beaucoup de la jambe mais
surtout le traumatisme et psychologique
il est énorme elle est sous
antidépresseur s anxiolitique mais elle
ne peut même plus travailler elle est
auxiliaire de enfin auxiliaire de vie
avec des enfants handicapés elle peut
plus être en contact avec les enfants
elle n'a plus de vie sociale et puis
surtout elle voit toujours c'est ce
qu'elle a confié aux enquêteurs elle
voit toujours son bébé mort parce que
quand elle a subi la césarienne à cause
d'une hémorragie interne du au choc elle
a demandé on lui lui a fait voir son
enfant et elle a confié aux enquêteurs
se souvenir avoir compté les les les
doigts de de sa fille donc elle est
traumatisée enfin c'est vraiment pour
elle c'est sa vie est devenue un enfer
et et aujourd'hui bah elle est recluse
dans son appartement et c'est son mari
qui s'occupe s'occupe d'elle mais ça va
très très mal pour elle euh bah oui on
va prendre des nouvelles en tout cas on
lui souhaite un bon établissement voilà
et on pense bien sûr à cette famille
pour terminer point P on va parler de de
Gérard pardu avant d'accueillir LAN
Gérard par Dieu euh l'acteur alors il
est pas du tout au cœur d'une nouvelle
polémique comme on met sur ma fiche
puisque je vais vous raconter toute
l'histoire euh il y a des vidéos euh qui
sont en train de tourner de lui à Dubaï
ça a été balancé par BFM TV j'ai rien
contre en plus BFM j'aime plutôt bien
mais euh regardez ces photos qui ont
fait le tour des réseaux sociaux ce
weekend et je vais tout vous expliquer
ensuite euh tu viendras j'ai les infos
puisque c'est moi qui qui les ai donné
voilà j'ai eu des j'ai eu toutes les
personnes concernées euh regardez
d'abord la compile des vidéos
est
[Musique]
ce les médias
sont FM TV qui a lancé le truc he c'est
BFM TV qui a qui a lancé le le le truc
le problème c'est que voilà vérifier les
infos les Chéries c'est pas possible
sans rigoler de balancer ça sur BFM sans
vérifier les infos j'ai rien contre eux
mais là c'est pas possible alors bien
sûr le Parisien aussi a lancé l'info euh
bon après avoir retrouvé Xavier duupont
de Ligones ils ont relancé une nouvelle
info et après il vienent de nous dire à
nous qu'on qu'on lance des fake news
nous il y a eu une une fake news c'était
pas du tout une FA d'ailleurs c'était
les trois gars ici qui étaient de la
bravem les quatre gars et le gars dès
qu'il arrive il dit bien dès le début on
est je il y en a qu'un qui est de la
bravem et les trois autres non donc
voilà donc ils nous ont fait des
articles pour ça eux ils ont retrouvé
Exavier du pond de liigones et là ils
disent une nouvelle connerie puisque
regardez la vidéo de BFM TV c'est pas
possible les gars vous vous
décrédibilisez je suis désolé c'est
catastrophique c'est pour comment vous
voulez que les gens vous fassent
confiance derrière c'est catastrophique
regardez les proches de Jard pardu
disaient qu'ils étaient assez inquiets
pour son état de santé puisque l'acteur
est en plein dans une polémique hein il
est visé par trois plaintes pour viol et
agression sexuelle dont une qui a été
classée ensuite et ces vidéos he de
Gérard pardieu font beaucoup réagir les
internautes dans les commentaires en a
beaucoup qui se réjouissent de voir que
GG c'est comme ça il l'appelle bon a
l'air d'être plutôt en bonne santé et a
l'air de de de plutôt bien vivre malgré
cette polémique en revanche il y en a
d'autres qui sont très agacés en colère
même qui disent que finalement il a pas
l'air d'aller si mal que ça et ils y
voient une forme de provocation déjà il
y a un débat déjà il y a un débat parce
qu'il fait ce qu'il veut en fait il a de
par deil est pas tant qu'il est pas
condamné donc voilà mais mais donc le
Parisien piscine restaurant voiture de
sport à Dubaï le séjour fastueux de
Gérard pardieu les vidéos pas publié par
son ami Farid Kider montre les deux
hommes prenant du bon temps en vacances
euh on va on va on Farid nous a fait une
vidéo euh bien entendu nous a fait une
vidéo en exclusivité pour TPMP il a même
pas été appelé par BFM TV moi j'ai la
chance ce soit un ami donc voilà c'est
lui-même qui m'a dit qu' vaait lu faire
une vidéo Farid merci qui devait venir
ce soir il est dans le sud il est pas du
tout à Dubaï Farid k donc une fois de
plus n'importe quoi n'importe quoi mais
c'est comme compliment d'enquête on
avait le truc sur Gérard pard on a tous
montré ici que c'était n'importe quoi
hein d'ailleurs on veut voir le film et
sachez que j'ai eu maître Jérémy à sous
là il y a 1 heure à peu près avant de
venir à l'émission je peux vous dire là
lui il va attaquer sec et il est
persuadé et il est sûr il a toutes les
preuves que ça a été bidonné d'ailleurs
vous avez vu personne n'a réagi France
Télévision n complément d'enquête et
forcément je vous le dis euh BFM TV ils
sont ils sont derrière tristanex voilà
ils doivent le protéger aussi forcément
comme je vous l'ai dit voilà c'est c'est
et en plus BFM c'est des potes mais bon
voilà ils se protègent tous c'est
insupportable qui a qui a repris qui a
repris la démonstration de jéremi sous
ici personne parce qu'il ils veulent pas
ils veulent pas reprendre le truc voilà
alors là regardez far Kider va nous dire
pourquoi cette ces vidéos et chez
articles c'est n'importe quoi regardez
salut Cyril salut TPMP bah juste pour
vous annoncer que je ne suis pas à Dubaï
les vidéos qui ont été postées euh c'est
des vieilles vidéos qui datent de 2022 à
l' époque on était à Dubaï avec Gérard
quand il était en pleine forme bon je
comprends pas que BFM a même pas pris le
temps de de m'appeler pour me demander
si les infos étaient bonne et euh et
voilà bon ça charne encore hein mais bon
faut laisser faire merci far qui garde
le sourire au moins far je l'embrasse
d'ailleurs le frér extrêment grave c'est
extrêmement grave ça tourne sur des FM
ça tourne partout mais c'est c'est
catastrophique excusez-moi ça veut dire
que non seulement ils ne vérifi pas leur
sources et que leur sources c'est TikTok
parce qu'on les a vu les TikTok circuler
et en plus surtout il ne les vérifi pas
quand ça les arrange quand ça va dans le
sens de leur idéologie urence enfoncé
Gérard par c'était la même chose pour
complément d'enquête donc là ils sont
dit c'est bon il fait la fête à Dubaï
non les gars vérifie c'est pas un TikTok
qui fait FO d'information en plus il
suffisait de dérouler le fil pour se
rendre compte que ces vidéos
AVI c'est ce que j'ai fait et du coup on
se rend compte que les vidéos ont été
posté le 15 février 2022 déjà sur le
TikTok de Far Kider très simple à voir
d'aller dans les commentaires et les
premiers commentaires date d'il a un an
et rendez compte vous qui n rejoz à
20h53 de la gravité du truc ils ont tous
repris derrière alors que c'est un faux
bail voilà c'est un faux truc ça date de
2022 merci Farid de nous le dire Gérard
pard je suis même pas sûr qu'il soit à
Dubaï actuellement parce qu'en tout cas
il est pas du tout avec Farid Farid il
est dans le sud il est avec ses enfants
dans le sud donc il est pas du tout à
Dubaï avec Gérard pard en train de nager
dans une piscine et même s'il était à
Duba pare pas dans les
ties qu' vont dire ils vont dire alors
je vais te dire ils vont faire
exactement comme ils ont fait sur
complément d'enquête ils ont tous ils
sont tous réagis en disant ouais mais il
a quand même dit ça d'une femme
attentionin donc voilà mais ça on a pas
dit le contraire on a dit juste qu'il y
avait un vis de forme et qu'il avent
fait croire qu'il parlait d'une petite
fille alors qu'il parlait d'une femme
sachez-le en plus ils ont tourné en 4K
et en 4K tu peux V zoom exactement avec
énormément de qualité pour qu'on ne voit
pas la cavalière derrière donc attention
c'est quand même des c'est quand même
des attention c'est des professionnels
he sous prétexte parce que c'est
toujours eux qui passent pour les
gentils sachezle les vrais méchants ce
sont eux et c'est eux qui font que des
magouilles sachez-le voilà moi vous
l'avez vu mon complément d'enquête il y
a pas de magouille donc voilà donc en
plus ils ont cherché ils ont mis que des
conneries voilà il y a que des conneries
en c'est que de la merde voilà mais je
peux vous dire ceux qui m'agouillent le
plus c'est eux et d'ailleurs je le redis
on aura notre enquête complémentaire qui
va sortir vous verrez et je vais
rajouter des chos d'ailleurs dans
enquête complémentaire c'est pour ça
qu'on va un petit peu le décaler parce
que j'ai des nouvelles infos je peux te
dire que c'est du très très loin on m'a
appelé expressément ce weekend pour me
donner des nouvelles infos sur toute
l'histoire donc t'inquiète pas on va
juste rajouter ça et ce que j'aime pas
c'est qu'en plus de donner les mauvaises
infos il interprète les images c'est que
parce qu'il est dans une piscine il se
la coule dou comme s'il s'en foutait de
l'affaire comme si c'était une réponse
aux accation un homme même accusé a le
droit d'être à Dubaï a le droit d'être
dans une piscine et c'est pas pour ça
qu'il s'en fout de l'affaire et qui se
la coule dou c'est dégueulasse de faire
ça voilà merci en tout cas Palomba et
merci Bertrand DESC j'espère que on va
avoir des meilleures nouvelles pour le
roi Charles on va passer tout de suite à
l'invit